die masken affäre hat das vertrauen
vieler in die politik erschüttert
auch das von jenny böken als
musikproduzent hat in die korona krise
hart getroffen dass manche politiker
sich an genau dieser krise persönlich
bereichern macht ihn wütend
man muss jeden euro zweimal umdrehen und
dann kriegt man halt irgendwelche
schlagzeilen um die ohren gepfeffert
über masken affäre hier und ich sag
jetzt mal mit meinen worten geld wird
irgendwie dorthin geleitet wo es nicht
hin solche politiker bereichern sich das
kotzen nur noch an danny bokelmann will
dass sich endlich etwas ändert er hat
deshalb einen offenen brief der
internetplattform abgeordnetenwatch.de
als erstunterzeichner unterschrieben
gemeinsam mit anderen prominenten wie
dem schauspieler armin rohde und dem
cartoonisten ralph ruthe und inzwischen
mehr als 13.000 bürgern
der offene brief appelliert an alle
fraktionen des deutschen bundestags
wirksame maßnahmen zu beschließen die
fehler im system zu beheben die seit
jahren bekannt sein
die affären der letzten wochen im
schnelldurchlauf
der stellvertretende vorsitzende der
cdu/csu-fraktion georg nüßlein der
cdu-abgeordnete nikolas löbel und der
csu landtagsabgeordnete und ehemalige
bayerische justizminister alfred sauter
sie alle sollen masken weitervermittelt
und dafür zum teil provisionen in
millionenhöhe kassiert haben
andere unionspolitiker sollen
schmiergelder aus aserbaidschan erhalten
haben
für die spenden finanzierte organisation
abgeordnetenwatch.de ist all das keine
überraschung
sie kritisiert seit jahren es fehle der
deutschen politik an transparenz und es
fehle der politische wille sie
durchzusetzen
wir sind mit klare helming der
sprecherin für abgeordnetenwatch.de
verabredet schon seit 16 jahren sammelt
die internetplattform daten über die
nebenverdienste von abgeordneten nicht
nur um einzelfälle geht sondern um einen
systemfehler in unserer politik wie
meinen sie das die cdu csu hat das lange
versucht zu argumentieren dass das nur
einzelfälle sind mit den masken deals
usw
aber es sind einfach so viele fälle die
immer wieder kommen dass wir uns klar
ist dass das system hat was verschluckt
vielleicht gibts denn derzeit für
abgeordnete
also wir haben general einfach viel zu
wenig informationen zum beispiel über
die nebenjobs von abgeordnete und
abgeordnete müssen zwar angaben machen
zu ihren nebentätigkeiten die sind aber
unvollständig und gehen einfach nicht
ein blick auf die nebeneinnahmen der
bundestagsabgeordneten zeigt in summe
bewegen sie sich in millionenhöhe 8,7
millionen euro brutto verdienten
cdu-abgeordnete in dieser wahlperiode
neben ihrer diät 5,8 millionen euro die
csu und die fdp 5 millionen die grünen
hatten insgesamt nur 120.000 euro
nebeneinnahmen
prinzipiell sind neben einnahmen legal
aber abgeordnetenwatch.de kritisiert
dass es über die geschäftskontakte der
volksvertreter zu wenig transparenz geht
und über geschäftspartnerin von
abgeordnete es gibt einige abgeordnete
die als berater arbeiten und die dann
verschwiegenheitspflichten vereinbar mit
ihren mandanten
und da gibt es abgeordnete die 15.000
euro im monat kassieren von mandant 1
wir wissen nicht wer das ist wo wir
nicht wissen ob es einen
interessenkonflikt gibt und der verdacht
liegt nahe dass ein interessenkonflikt
gibt weil sonst könnten die politiker ja
einfach sagen mit ihm zu sprechen
warum gibt es bisher so wenig regeln die
mehr transparenz schaffen
[Musik]
wir treffen einen abgeordneten der sich
seit vielen jahren für schärfere gesetze
einsetzt deshalb immer wieder aneckt
marco bülow
16 jahre lang war marco bülow mitglied
der spd bundestagsfraktion 2015 startete
er eine transparenzoffensive mit dem
ziel alle nebeneinkünfte lobby kontakte
dienstreisen und einladungen
offenzulegen nur 43 parlamentarier
schlossen sich ihm damals an die massen
affäre jetzt hat ja wirklich verziehen
emotionen gesorgt ist dass wir sie nur
die spitze des eisbergs auf jeden fall
und es geht auch nicht nur um korruption
erstens glaube ich es sind noch viel
mehr beteiligt an anderen dingen die
nicht offenbart werden und zweitens
glaube ich es gibt eine große grauzone
die genau zwischen korruption und einer
vermengung von profitinteressen und dann
doch politik liegen
und da wir unsere eigenen regeln geben
ist vieles nicht verboten sondern
ziemlich legal wie aktienoptionen
versprechen des wechsels in die
wirtschaft mit hohen abfindungen und so
weiter das ist alles nicht verboten weil
wir unsere regeln selbst gehen
sie haben wir wirklich einen einblick
auch diskussionen mit ihren eigenen
kollegen abgeordneten ist man denn dann
mit nebentätigkeiten bisher umgegangen
es gilt das ist ja das verrückte das
gilt eigentlich der als guter politiker
als erfolgreicher politiker der
besonders viele nebeneinkünfte hat der
besonders gute kontakte hat der zwischen
den welten unterwegs ist der in
aufsichtsräten sitzt und auch geschenke
bekommt das ist eigentlich der
erfolgreiche und dem wollen natürlich
anderen nacheifern steinbrück war der
fachpolitiker der seriöse vorzeige
mensch den wir in der partei hatten und
ich meine es ja nicht ohne grund
kanzlerkandidat geworden und hatte die
höchsten zur derzeitigen höchst höchsten
nebeneinkünfte hauptsächlich durch
vorträge bei sehr profitablen
unternehmen und natürlich hat er dann
keine zeit er brauche nicht viel in der
fraktion
seine eigentliche arbeit zu machen aber
trotz das hat keinen gestört und das
dass das hat mich immer so angefixt also
das ist da irgendwo ist wo ich gegen
wände gelaufen nämlich gesagt hat das
kann doch nicht unser ansehen sein und
das war die spd-fraktion nicht gegen
jung im november 2008 10 trat marco
bülow aus der spd aus blieb aber
fraktionsloser abgeordneter im bundestag
er wollte die politik der großen
koalition nicht länger vertreten
zwei jahre später trat er in die satire
partei die partei ein für die er nun
erneut für den bundestag kandidiert
aber drei viertel der abgeordnete haben
gar keine nebenverdienste da muss man
jetzt auch mal sagen drei viertel machen
sie die sehen dass nach ihrem hauptjob
an und die drei viertel sind nicht stark
genug das viertel ein bisschen
einzudämmen
erstmals unter welcher bei die würden
gerne und kommen aber nicht in die
verlegenheit
und dann gibt es welche die wollen in
ruhe arbeiten und die wissen wenn sie
sich dann anlegen mit denen die diese
nebeneinkünfte haben da sind meistens
eben die wichtigsten und die die das
sagen haben
dann wird ihr job nicht mehr ganz so
einfach haben sie auch so erlebnissen ja
habe ich total so erlebt
wir sind mit matthias tatge verabredet
dem verhandlungsführer der spd
intransparenz und lobbyismus fragen
seit 2013 sitzt er im bundestag
er war also lange jahre fraktionskollege
von marco bülow
das ist ja das verrückte das gilt
eigentlich als großer politiker
erfolgreicher politiker der besonders
viele nehmen das hat keine stadt
beschreibt marco bülow hier ein
politisches klima das ein fehler im
system ist oder dass der fehler im
system sogar ist das ansehen von
abgeordneten steigt nicht mit der anzahl
der nebentätigkeiten und natürlich peer
steinbrück war der einzige der das
gemacht hat oder im größeren stil
gemacht hat das hat uns alle geärgert
und das dass die wertigkeit eines
abgeordneten steigert das ist wirklich
nicht wahr in der union kann ich das
nicht so anwalt habe ich schon relativ
viele fälle sind die dort aufgefallen
sind wie dort das klima gewesen ist bei
uns ist das nicht der fall
wenn es um transparenz fragen geht zeigt
die spd gerne auf cdu und csu wir
wollten schon immer mehr transparenz nur
leider sei das mit der union nicht zu
machen gewesen
kann man sich auf die position
zurückziehen als regierungsmitglied zu
sagen wir haben es beim
koalitionspartner nicht durchgebracht
na ja wir haben es ja immer schon
gefordert diese all diese dinge das
haben sie ja beim lobbyregister noch ein
extremer form gesehen haben wir zehn
jahre gefordert dass meine ich gar nicht
darum geht's nicht aber es gibt ja
politische projekte die ihnen so wichtig
waren dass sie im koalitionsvertrag
gelandet sind und gesagt haben das
müssen wir durchsetzen und das war hier
offensichtlich nicht
das stimmt das war hier nicht der fall
aber wir hatten eben auch diese extreme
häufung in der vergangenheit nicht so
dass auch die die notwendigkeit in dem
verschärft maße nicht bestanden hat und
und wenn solche dinge passieren dann
muss natürlich politik reagieren oder
ich sag's mal anders im bereich der
transparenz im parlamentarismus passiert
immer nur etwas wenn etwas passiert ist
gerade bei der veröffentlichung von
nebentätigkeiten hätte transparenz für
viel mehr klarheit gesorgt
bisher müssen abgeordnete ihre
nebeneinnahmen in einem komplizierten
stufen system angeben allerdings nicht
auf euro und cent es bleibt oft unklar
woher die einnahmen genau kommen und wie
hoch der tatsächliche gewinn ist
auf platz eins der neben verdiener ist
derzeit der csu abgeordnete sebastian
bremen seit 2000 17 hatte er neben
seinem mandat nach berechnungen von
abgeordnetenwatch.de 3,1 millionen euro
nebenverdienst durch mehrere
steuerberatungsfirma gregor gysi von den
linken verdiente nebenher geschätzt
470.000 euro durch vorträge ähnlich wie
der fdp vorsitzende christian lind nacht
geschätzt 400 24.500 euro
cdu und csu haben lange gemeinschaftlich
gegen mehr transparenz und strengere
regeln bei den nebenverdiensten der
abgeordneten gestimmt auch deshalb
konnten einzelne politiker über jahre
ein lukratives geschäftsmodell aufbauen
den politischen berater über eigene
firmen versilberten sie sich ihre
politischen kontakte und netzwerke wie
etwa der mannheimer cdu politiker
nikolas löbel der 34 jährige kassierte
für seinen einsatz als vermittler von
corona schutzmasken eine provision in
höhe von 250.000 euro
nur ein einzelfall oder ein fehler im
system
in berlin treffen wir patrick schnieder
parlamentarischer geschäftsführer der
cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
ich weiß nicht ob über einen fehler im
system werden kann wir haben regeln
gehabt sehr weitreichende regeln aber
die waren offensichtlich nicht
weitreichend genug in manchen fällen
weil eben dinge passiert sind die ich
mir nicht hätte vorstellen können dass
kollegen das machen wir haben auch
vertrauen gesetzt gegenüber abgeordneten
und dieses vertrauen ist in diesen
fällen missbraucht worden
die masken affäre setzt die union unter
größten politischen druck und plötzlich
geht was lange zeit unmöglich schien
cdu csu spd grüne und linke erarbeiten
gemeinsam ein neues viel strengeres
abgeordnetengesetz danach werden zum
ersten mal überhaupt nebeneinkünfte von
abgeordneten auf euro und cent
veröffentlicht und aktienoptionen
offengelegt in verbindung mit ihrem
mandat dürfen abgeordnete zukünftig
nicht mehr als politische berater
arbeiten keiner bezahlten lobby oder
vortragstätigkeit nachgehen und auch
keine geldspenden mehr annehmen
wir gehen mit dem neuen
abgeordnetengesetz wirklich an die
absolute grenze dessen was
verfassungsrechtlich möglich es gibt
einzelne juristen die aussagen mann gibt
an der einen stelle vielleicht schon
darüber hinaus mit den änderungen die
jetzt passieren ist damit so etwas wie
eine maske affäre unmöglich geworden
sie wird jedenfalls unwahrscheinlicher
aber das ist so ähnliche mit dem
diebstahls paragraf im strafgesetzbuch
der diebstahl ist auch verboten und
dennoch findet der stadt bei
entsprechender krimineller energie kann
ich nicht jeden fall ausschließen der in
zukunft passieren könnte
viele der jetzt geplanten änderungen
fordern transparenz organisationen wie
abgeordnetenwatch.de schon seit jahren
das ist erst mal ein richtiger schritt
aber es ist natürlich bitter dass dafür
erst die massen affäre nötig war damit
bewegung in die sache kommt
klarer helming geht der neue
gesetzentwurf der noch nicht weit genug
das ist jetzt auch eine transparenz
kommission geben muss also eine
prüfinstanz die sicherstellt dass die
abgeordneten ihre angaben richtig
gemacht haben also dass es nicht
irgendwelche nebenjobs gibt die
abgeordnete gar nicht angegeben haben
zum beispiel im augenblick passiert das
noch vertrauen
das soll halt leider auch so bleiben mit
dem neuen gesetz dass der
bundestagspräsident alleine dafür
zuständig ist zu kontrollieren ob die
abgeordneten ihre angaben richtig machen
also im augenblick und so soll es auch
bleiben so soll es bleiben kontrolliert
die politik sich selbst politik
kontrolliert sich selbst und das ist
natürlich ein großes problem
und was mit dem neuen gesetz gar nicht
geklärt ist wie groß ist der einfluss
von außen auf politik wie stark die
macht der lobby welt in den letzten
jahren sind hunderte büros rund um den
bundestag entstanden
interessenvertretungen für die
wirtschaft organisationen finanz starke
verbände wie viele lobbyisten es gibt
weiß niemand genau
schätzungen sprechen von 6.000 das wären
9 lobbyisten auf einen abgeordneten
lobbyismus ist an sich nichts schlechtes
interessenvertretung gehört zur
demokratie
aber timo lange von lobbycontrol
beobachtet deren einfluss auf die
politik kritisch
lobbyismus ist nah dran an der politik
die verbindung sind manchmal zu nah
schwierig ist es wenn dann eben das
große macht ungleichgewichte gibt wer
hat mehr einfluss wer setzt sich durch
nicht immer mit dem besseren argument
sondern einfach aufgrund der lobby kraft
diese lobby kraft zeigt zum beispiel die
stiftung familienunternehmen die sich
vor allem für großunternehmen und die
sehr wohlhabenden einsetzt die haben
sich sehr stark gemacht für eine sehr
weiche erbschaftssteuerreform was für
sehr viel kritik gesorgt hat
die lobbyagentur top setzt dagegen auf
insiderwissen
das besondere ist dass sie sehr viele
ehemalige politikerinnen und politiker
angeworben haben die dann natürlich ein
netzwerk dann den zahlenden verfügung
der seitenwechsel vom politiker zum
lobbyisten zieht sich quer durch alle
parteien
bisher mussten lobby firmen dabei nicht
einmal angeben wer genau für sie
arbeitet das ändert sich nun
union und spd haben sich auf die
einführung eines lobby registers
verständigt das soll für mehr
transparenz im märz hat der bundestag
beschlossen von nun an müssen sich alle
lobbyisten die mit politikern in kontakt
kommen wollen offiziell registrieren und
angeben wer ihre auftraggeber sind wie
sie sich finanzieren und wie viel sie
für lobbyarbeit aufwenden bezahlt der
lobbyismus von abgeordneten gegenüber
der regierung ist verboten
timo lange und vielen anderen kritikern
geht das neue gesetz aber nicht weit
genug
also mit dem lobbyregister eingesetzt so
wie es jetzt verabschiedet wurde sind
wir nicht zufrieden ein ganz großes
manko ist dass es kein legislativen
fußabdruck geben wird das heißt es wird
nicht wirklich transparenter welche
lobbyisten an welcher stelle und wie auf
einen gesetzentwurf eingewirkt haben und
damit ist das eigentlich ein bisschen
ein halbes register das macht
transparenter wer sind die lobbyisten
wer sind die auftraggeber dass es gut
aber wie nehmen sie einfluss und an
welcher stelle das wird eben weiter
unsichtbar bleiben
ist das neue deutsche lobbyregister ein
zahnloser tiger
das eu parlament hat den weg isla tiven
fußabdruck schon vor jahren eingeführt
genauso eu staaten wie zb estland oder
slowenien
einer der auslöser für das neue lobby
register war die affäre am tor im juni
2020 bringt der spiegel ans licht der
jungs da der cdu philipp am tor setzt
sich mit einem brief beim
wirtschaftsminister für das
amerikanische startup unternehmen gastes
intelligence 1 erhält später
aktienoptionen im wert von bis zu
250.000 dollar die affäre sorgt für ein
politisches beben philipp amthor
entschuldigt sich gibt die
aktienoptionen zurück laut dem
abgeordnetengesetz kann ihm nichts
vorgeworfen werden erst jetzt mit den
neu geplanten strengeren regeln werden
aktienoptionen meldepflichtig kurz
darauf verzichtete am tor auf den
landesvorsitz der cdu
doch dieses jahr im januar wählten die
parteibasis in mecklenburg vorpommern zu
ihrem spitzenkandidaten für den
bundestag mit 90 prozent
wir treffen zwei cdu kommunalpolitiker
in amtes heimatstadt ueckermünder
ich war von der sache ja so dass wir das
gefühl hatten dass er das gedauert das
ist ein fehler war
und dann war das für uns gegessen man
muss auch mal dann nochmal ruhe
wir konzentrieren uns auf unsere
politische arbeit hier vor ort und da
ist philipp am tor für uns eine größe
weitere diskussion braucht man da
eigentlich gar nicht dazu führen
wir treffen philipp amthor persönlich im
letzten jahr hat er noch auf die
kandidatur auf den landesvorsitz der cdu
in mecklenburg vorpommern verzichtet
jetzt hat er sich zum spitzenkandidaten
seines landes für den bundestag wählen
lassen
ich habe einen politischen fehler
eingestanden und die leute haben damit
auch glaube ich gesehen dass ich damit
transparent umgegangen bin und dass es
auch die erwartung die die menschen
haben und für mich war es sehr wichtig
einstimmig wieder nominiert worden zu
sein für den bundestag
umso dankbarer bin ich hier getragen zu
sein von dem starken rückhalt meiner
heimatregion
rechtlich kann man nichts vorwerfen aber
bei der bevölkerung da gab es sehr viel
wut sehr viel empörung wieder oben
verdienen jetzt noch geld neben ihren
10.000 euro diese eh schon haben können
sie das nachvollziehen
ja definitiv ich habe durch die ganze
debatte natürlich persönlich an
sensibilität gewonnen ich habe da einen
fehler gemacht ich habe mich an greifbar
gemacht und das wirft natürlich dann
nicht nur ein schlechtes licht auf einen
selbst mit diesen politischen fehler
sondern insgesamt und das ist etwas das
mir leidtun in zukunft ist es ja nicht
mehr erlaubt dass ein abgeordneter als
abi ist von habe ich auch nicht ich habe
die aktienoptionen nicht erhalten für
politische interessenvertretung das will
ich noch mal deutlich betonen ich habe
mich später in der firma engagiert
sozusagen für firmen gezogene dinge und
ich habe nicht bezahlt wurden für
politische interessen trotz aber sie
sind natürlich als abgeordneter eine
pension gestaunt dass man da sie höhere
zugang zur macht das ist einer der
charts mineralisierungs fähig sie sagen
sie haben einen fehler gemacht hätte
dann die cdu nicht schon viel früher
regularien schaffen kann dass man solche
fehler gar nicht erst machen kann
besser wäre es gewesen wenn solche
regulierungen sozusagen vorausschauend
erfolgt aber ich will auch noch mal aus
persönlicher ansehung sagen es geht
nicht nur um die frage wie sieht der
rechtsrahmen aus sondern auch die
persönliche sensibilität zu haben dafür
das würde ich für mich entscheiden keine
nebentätigkeiten nachzugehen wo der
anschein entsteht dass man sie in einen
zusammenhang mit dem politischen mandat
bringt
fest steht nach den neuen regeln sind
aktienoptionen nun meldepflichtig aber
solange ein abgeordneter erklärt dass er
diese nicht in verbindung mit seinem
mandat erworben hat bleiben sie
weiterhin ein möglicher lukrativer
nebenverdienst philipp amthor jedenfalls
ist wieder zurück auf der großen
politischen bühne
für den politikwissenschaftler thomas
könig keine überraschung
diese kurzlebigkeit dass man
mittlerweile schon fast planen kann
politisch was muss ich tun wenn ich mal
zufälligerweise entdeckt werde sechs
wochen weg alles ausschalten dann kann
ich wieder durchstarten
also das ist natürlich etwas was aber
glaube ich schon bei der bevölkerung so
unwohlsein soll unbehagen das mag so
bauchgefühl sein dass da was nicht in
ordnung ist erzeugt was macht dieses
unwohlsein mit unserer demokratie wie
groß ist das vertrauen in unsere politik
das zdf-politbarometer stellt für
zdfzoom anfang mai diese frage das
ergebnis 53,5 prozent der menschen haben
in die politik nicht so großes und 9,2
prozent gar kein vertrauen
großes vertrauen haben dagegen nur 33 6%
sehr großes 1,7
das hat wohl auch mit den affären der
letzten jahre zu tun um verlorenes
vertrauen wieder herzustellen muss
politik noch transparenter werden
strengere klarere regeln formulieren und
unabhängige kontrollen möglich machen
und das nicht erst dann wenn sie mit dem
rücken zur wand steht